la laïcité c'est la liberté de
conscience
mais c'est aussi des rêves faisons vivre
la laïcité mais ne la tue en pas en la
contrôlant la laïcité la laïcité la
laïcité parce que c'est le coeur que la
république et donc de l'école la laïcité
un condiment inscrit dans la loi depuis
plus d'un siècle et qui fait irruption
intervalles réguliers dans l'actualité
parmi les sujets sensibles les menus des
cantines scolaires
un dossier où les mères tâtonne bien
souvent habitants et élus voient
apparaître sur leur commune une mosquée
sans savoir combien elle a coûté ni
qu'il a financé la cour de cassation
donne raison à la crèche baby loup et
confirme le licenciement de la salariée
voilée aux revendications religieuses en
entreprise polémique sur le port à la
cantine incidents dans les hôpitaux
ces cas d'école illustre les crispations
actuel autour de la laïcité
dans ce contexte les radicaux de gauche
au sénat ont déposé une proposition de
loi pour inscrire la loi de 1905 dans la
constitution
aux yeux du président du groupe
il est urgent de stopper les ajustements
autour de ce texte
ce qui est évident aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on voit bien la montée des
communautarismes et chaque fois qu'on
lâche un petit peu sur le
communautarisme on met en danger la
république
et là dessus nous nous sommes tout à
fait intransigeant il n'y a pas
contrairement à ce que j'entends
deux conceptions de la laïcité il n'y en
a qu'une celle de la loi de 1905
l'objectif est d'intégrer à la
constitution les deux premiers articles
de loi régissant la séparation des
églises et de l'état
la république assure la liberté de
conscience
elle garantit le libre exercice des
cultes la république ne reconnaît ne
salarie ni ne subventionne aucun culte
lors du débat en séance les radicaux se
retrouve isolé une majorité de sénateurs
sont d'accord pour constater le
développement du communautarisme mais ne
semble pas prêt à graver la loi de 1905
dans la constitution
évitons sur le coup de l'émotion de
défaire les équilibres fragiles que les
législations succès de steve et juristes
présents sans permis d'atteindre la loi
de 1905 est un pas historique
un acte fondateur que l'on doit célébrer
mais aucune loi n'est l'alpha et l'oméga
d'un principe ne la mettons pas sous une
cloche de verre
appliquons la loi adaptons là quand il
le faut faisons vivre la laïcité mais ne
la tue on pas en la conjuguant
faire vivre la laïcité un défi quotidien
que de nombreux acteurs pente de relever
place de la religion dans l'entreprise
financement des lieux de culte pédagogie
dans les écoles à partir de plusieurs
exemples nous sommes allés voir comment
la laïcité s'applique aujourd'hui
première étape à chalon sur saône
la ville s'est retrouvé au coeur d'une
polémique nationale autour de la
suppression des menus de substitution au
port au cours de la campagne des
dernières élections départementales
le maire gilles platret élus en 2014
annonce que les cantines des écoles
primaires de sa ville serviront un plat
unique dès la rentrée 2015
six mois après l'entrée en vigueur de la
mesure
les esprits se sont calmés et le
quotidien a repris ses droits
comme dans cette école du centre-ville
la décision marque une rupture avec une
pratique en place depuis plus de trente
ans jusqu'à la dernière rentrée
un menu alternatif était proposée les
jours ou du port était servi dans les
réfectoires les équipes ont dû ajuster
la prise en charge
mais la mesure n'a pas bouleversé
l'organisation et à de la viande
et puis de la purée ce qu'ils mangent
pas de viande ils ont capturé
c'est tout simple voilà c'est tout
simple n'est pas plus simple
cette école propose trois services
chaque midi les plats à base de porc
sont servis une vingtaine de fois dans
l'année
ces jours là les agents veillent à
équilibrer les rations de ceux qui
refusent d'en manger c'est pas des
enfants qui vont ressortir de la cantine
avec le ventre vide un ânon monde et
légumes et il ya des féculents
il ya le fromage les fruits il ya
l'entrée
chaque jour deux mille écoliers soit
près de la moitié des enfants scolarisés
dans la ville mangent à la cantine la
fin des menus de substitution n'a pas
entraîné une chute de la fréquentation
mais les parents d'élèves ont quand même
eu du mal à comprendre la démarche de la
mairie parents d'élèves de chalon sur
saône
jusqu'à maintenant se trouvait bien dans
le système mis en place depuis 30 ans
l'arrêt du repas de substitution port ou
pas encore toute façon à créer un
malaise pendant quelques mois
dérange encore je dirais une 15 à 20
personnes sur la population globale de
chalon des parents d'élèves attaqué en
justice par une association de défense
des musulmans
la ville est dans l'attenté d'une
décision du tribunal administratif de
dijon pour justifier son choix
la mairie rappelle que la restauration
scolaire est un service facultatif et
s'appuie sur les travaux de
l'association des maires de france qui
se prononce contre l'aménagement des
menus si l'élu après une décision
clivante
c'est pour réaffirmer un principe la
laïcité impose la neutralité du service
public
à partir du moment où vous intégrer dans
le fonctionnement et l'organisation de
votre service une norme religieuse en
l'occurrence une prescription une
interdiction religieuse de consommer
certains plats alors vous faites droit à
la prescription religieuse dont je
trouve qu'elle possède une légitimité
mais à titre privé et pas dans
l'organisation d'un service public
donc on a souhaité véritablement revenir
à une pratique de neutralité
avec cette mesure le maire s'est attiré
des critiques jusque dans sa famille
politique
mais son initiative a aussi été imitée
au moins dix communes ont déjà suivi
l'exemple de chalon sur saône
un choix principalement motivée par une
volonté des maires de mettre un frein
aux demandes de menus confessionnels
même si il peut y avoir la frustration
et même si on prend une pratique
religieuse à rebrousse poil on le fait
avec un but précis c'est qu'en traitant
les enfants tous de la même manière on
pense d'abord à leur unité à leur
égalité avant de penser à leurs
différences cette approche rigoureuse
est loin de faire l'unanimité
l'égalité au sens de la laïcité c'est
une égalité on essaye de
tenir compte des spécificités de chacun
parce qu'on voit bien que le menu qui
est supposé être un menu neutre c'est
pas un menu neutre en fait il correspond
à notre culture notre culture culinaire
notre histoire culinaire
donc ça veut dire qu'il va finalement
favorisé certains ceux qui sont habitués
à ce type de menu au détriment des
autres ces menus de substitution les
existe depuis très longtemps
comme on avait à une époque le poisson
le vendredi on avait inclus dans les
restes les menus des restaurations
scolaires des menus sans viande de porc
pour riespach respect je n'étais pas
catho musulmans laïques etc
c'était une forme consensuelle de la
république et revenir en arrière ça
s'appelle ça met de l'huile sur le feu
par contre qu'on n'aille pas plus loin
entre le cacher le halal c'est là je
suis d'accord dans les entreprises aussi
la question confessionnelle se pose
une récente étude révèle que 23 % des
managers sont régulièrement confrontés
au fait religieux
ce chiffre a doublé en un an
direction la courneuve chez paprec
numéro 1 français dans le recyclage du
papier du carton en 2014 le groupe
installé en seine saint denis à adopter
en interne une charte de la laïcité qui
proscrit tous les signes religieux au
travail
implanté depuis plus de 20 ans dans ce
territoire sensible
le fondateur cherche à préserver son
entreprise détention extérieur en a été
extrêmement surpris d'une chose c'est
que en étant des champions de la
diversité on aurait pu imaginer qu il
fallait qu on fasse beaucoup
d'accommodement autour de tous ses
principes mais la demande de notre
personnel était une demande d'être très
rigoureux et d'être très rigoureux et en
fait donc on y viendra d'appliquer la
laïcité en entreprise parce qu'eux-mêmes
sont inquiets des pressions
communautaires les gens qui sont
convaincus comme nous de cette
initiative on le fait au titre de la
paix sociale 56 nationalités composent
les effectifs de paprec les ressources
humaines joue un rôle clé pour maintenir
la cohésion et ce dès l' embauche
quand les gens viennent et notamment
pour les entretiens au recrutement
en fait là c'est le salon d'accueil et
donc les gens donc lie à l'aquila et
donc on fait à temps et enfin patienter
les gens ici et donc normalement les
gens quand ils s'assoient il regarde et
vois nos valeurs et la charte de la
laïcité la diversité paprec est à ce
jour la seule compagnie avec un
règlement intérieur aussi strictes après
un débat avec les représentants du
personnel
la charte a pourtant été approuvé par
son % des salariés
en fait je pense que si on avait un jour
comme ça sans avoir fait sans avoir une
vraie politique de diversité pendant 20
ans
c'en est arrivé avec une charte de la
laïcité je pense qu'on n'aurait pas eu
du tout consensus s'arrête pas été
compris en fait le consensus en la mais
on a depuis longtemps c'est à dire que
lorsque paprec a été créée comme on l'a
vu tout à l'heure sur notre charte sur
de nos valeurs de nos valeurs la
première valeur et c'est vraiment une
vraie
elle a vraiment une réalité cette valeur
c'est la diversité
une centaine d'entreprises a déjà
demandé des conseils à la direction pour
éviter de se retrouver dans des
situations de blocage comme à la ratp ou
des entorses à la laïcité sont signalés
ces entreprises n'ont pas veillé à avoir
une diversité dans leur recrutement et
ce depuis des années des années ce qui
fait que du coup ces entreprises se
retrouvent soit sur certaines de leurs
usines ou de leurs deux lieux de
production avec une forte concentration
un endroit donné d'une communauté quelle
qu'elle soit d'une communauté et du coup
la communauté excluant du coup toute
autre personne venant d'une autre
communauté et là c'est compliqué de
faire marche arrière
moustapha chauffeur depuis sept ans voit
avant tout la charte comme un moyen de
préserver un environnement de travail
serein la religion c'est une conviction
personnelle n'a pas été initié dans
l'entreprise on est venu on est dans
l'entreprise pour faire effectuer un
travail et on doit faire que ce travail
là la religion c'est à la maison la
laïcité c'est quoi c'est la liberté la
liberté de pratiquer sa roue de sa foi
dans un endroit fermé dans son dans son
corps et dans sa tête
l'entreprise à aucun moment le code du
travail permet à l'employeur de limiter
l'expression des convictions religieuses
sous certaines conditions
mais aujourd'hui la charte va au delà de
la législation actuelle si un salarié
décide de l'attaqué l'entreprise n'est
pas à l'abri d'une condamnation
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
considère que le fait la liberté
religieuse tellement importante qu'elle
doit s'appliquer en entreprise alors ce
qu'est ce qui est clair aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a absolument besoin d'une
initiative parlementaire d'une
législation qui permettrait à cette
occasion qu on applique ce que nous on a
appliqué et j'allais dire pour être
objectif en roulant un peu soin à bandes
blanches étendre aux entreprises la
règle de neutralité existant dans les
services publics
la proposition n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour des parlementaires c'est un vrai
problème parce que juridiquement il n'y
a pas vraiment de choses qui existent
et si on propose aujourd'hui une loi
donc sur la laïcité dans les entreprises
on est dans une période un peu difficile
là je me mettrais si ça me venait à
l'idée dans le rôle de la provocatrice
et ce serait pas la laïcité que je
défends bien sûr que j'aimerais de temps
en temps il faut être utopiste pour
faire avancer ses idées
ali un peu plus loin etc mais en même
temps il faut pas aller au plus loin au
détriment de certaines personnes qui ont
besoin de travailler
et qui ont besoin donc c'est compliqué
ces difficultés autour de la laïcité
s'étendent aussi au financement des
lieux de culte l'état entretient les
églises érigés avant 1905
mais les nouvelles constructions sont à
la charge des croyants le financement du
personnel du culte et des lieux de culte
ne sont pas autorisés dans la loi de
mais il n'y avait pas des musulmans à
l'époque et les juifs pour voiliers eux
mêmes à la construction de leur lieu de
culte et de et le paiement du personnel
même aujourd'hui encore mais comme c'est
une communauté très pauvre ouvrière le
groupe des descendants d immigrés des
années soixante dix et ceux qui sont
encore en vie sont venus en 70
ce ne sont pas des groupes prospère
économiquement ils ont besoin de
subventions pour construire à
choisy-le-roi dans le val-de-marne les
musulmans de la ville se retrouve ici
pour prier
la prêche de vendredi s'est plaint
devant et là le chapiteau et les salles
tout plein un simple pavillon mise à
disposition par la mairie la salle de
prière principale est composé d'un
assemblage de baraquements de chantier
avec une capacité maximale de 400
personnes que comme le ramadan il arrive
c'est pareil ce soir en plein dans quoi
on est à bloc pour remédier à cette
situation il y a trois ans les
représentants musulmans de la ville
soutenue par la mairie ont lancé un
projet de construction de mosquée ont su
trouver exactement à l'emplacement qui a
vocation à devenir dans quelques années
la future mosquée de choisy le roi c'est
un terrain qui a été acheté par la
municipalité et qui est les cds
à l'association mais ces contreparties
de gamond d'un achat de votre part il ya
1800 mètres carrés sur la totalité du
terrain d'essai 8800 notariées ont
vocation à devenir à la fois le losc
emea sont structurels et galles cette
partie non religieuse du futur bâtiment
permet à la commune d'accorder des
subventions à l'association car la loi
de 1905 n'interdit pas le financement
des projets d'ordre culturel le geste
fort que la nuit fait reste quand même
modérée par rapport à l'engagement
financier de l'association thiérache et
irak et construit etc
il ya l'accompagnement il ya une éthique
et un échange qui est une réalité mais
vraiment dans le reste de l'irak le coût
total est estimé à 4 millions d'euros
les responsables religieux compte sur la
solidarité des fidèles pour réunir la
somme et espère que la mosquée sortira
de terre dans les cinq ans à venir pour
le maire de cette ville de 40 mille
habitants avec ce futur lieu de culte
il assure répondre aux besoins d'une
partie de sa population dans un souci
d'égalité
travailler pour qu'il y ait un lieu de
culte digne identifié répondre à des
normes notamment du plan local
d'urbanisme
ça va à l'encontre justement d'une
démarche communautariste ou le risque
peut être grand de se retrouver dans des
lieux non identifié dans des grands
ensembles où le risque justement de
renfermement sur soi est important de là
on travaille réellement sur une volonté
d'élargissement et de la mise en oeuvre
au grand jour de ski et la différence
des religions sur une commune les élus
manoeuvre aux frontières de la loi de
1905 en se portant garant des emprunts
contractés pour l'édification d'un lieu
de culte ou en accordant des baux
emphytéotiques qui permettent aux maires
de mettre à disposition un terrain
pendant un certain nombre d'années avant
de devenir propriétaire du bâtiment
ces outils on tue plusieurs effets ça a
permis un rattrapage en matière de lieux
de culte parce que il n'ya pas de
liberté de conscience au sens de la loi
de 1905
s'il n'y a pas d'endroit où ce qu'ils
croient puissent prier de manière je
dirais public au sens où ils peuvent
rentrer dans tout lieu public pour mis à
leur disposition pour pouvoir prier si
on dit oui à tel culte pour faire telle
chose
bien évidemment d'autres cultes
demanderont la même chose et au delà des
cultes d'ailleurs il peut y avoir
d'autres sensibilités qui ouvriront bien
sur la brèche vous savez les témoins de
jéhovah y construisent un certain nombre
de temples 1 sur le territoire de la
république
ils en ont le droit ils le font
eux-mêmes
point à la ligne
il existe une région française où le
financement des religions pose beaucoup
moins de problème en alsace moselle la
loi de 1905 ne s'applique pas une
exception hérités de l'histoire au
retour du territoire après la première
guerre mondiale le concorde installé
sous napoléon est resté en vigueur ce
traité signé avec le vatican organiser
les relations entre l'état et le cube de
catholiques puis protestants et juifs
l'islam n'est pas officiellement
reconnue par ce régime
cela n'a pas empêché les collectivités
locales d'accorder des faux pour la
construction de la grande mosquée de
strasbourg
inauguré en 2012
nous remercions d'abord la communauté
musulmane qui a donné le plus gros pour
commencer donc les études et les
consultations en suit donc la ville de
strasbourg qui a bien voulu mettre à
disposition le terrain + 10 % du coût
global de l'objectif
le conseil régional qui a donné 8 % le
conseil général qui a donné 8 pour sont
aussi l'argent public a couvert 30% sur
un budget total de 10 millions d'euros
l'engagement de l'état à donner une
crédibilité qui a permis d'attirer des
capitaux étrangers transparent le maroc
l'arabie saoudite et le koweït ont
assuré la moitié du financement le
projet a mis plus de vingt ans à se
concrétiser dans un contexte local
globalement favorables il réside en
particulier de l'alsace moselle a
contribué beaucoup dont la dent dont le
façonnement des mentalités
les alsaciens mosellans ont un rapport
pacifié avec la religion
nous n'avons pas un schiste ne vont pas
un combat la laïcité ici elle est perçue
comme modératrice comme il connaît une
conception qui pacifie les relations et
qu'ils n'ont pas et que nous on veut
n'aime pas autre exemple d'adaptation du
concordat al islam le cimetière musulman
municipal de strasbourg qui va mener en
faire quelqu'un est d'accord et toute la
famille est là je présente mes
condoléances
évoquer d'accord d'accord très contents
que les choses se passent ligne banc
pour l'enterrement et selon les rythmes
et les arrêts des orifices et laurie la
mairie a construit cet équipement pour
répondre à une saturation des carrés
confessionnels mais aussi à une demande
de la population c'est très important de
pouvoir contrer ses proches de pouvoir
le rendre visite chaque fois qu'on en a
envie et ça c'est très important en tout
cas pour l'intégration ouvert en 2012 ce
cimetière public intégralement musulmans
est le seul en france car sur le reste
du territoire il est interdit de bâtir
des lieux de sépulture séparées sur des
bases religieuses pour le construire le
maire a adopté une vision élargie du
concordat à l'islam pour moi la laïcité
ça consiste d'abord à pour les pouvoirs
publics à être dans la neutralité par
rapport aux différentes conditions
mais la neutralité ne veut pas dire se
désintéresser de ce qui se passe et donc
ma laïcité à moi si je puis dire
mais pas seulement à moi c'est de
faciliter l'exercice des cultes
dans la diversité de leurs pratiques en
alsace-moselle des voix plaident pour
que ce modèle d'exception soit vu comme
un laboratoire pour repenser la laïcité
la proposition a du mal à convaincre en
dehors de la région
alors on va pas importer les vestiges de
l'histoire au 21ème siècle
je vais faire maintenant pour
réorganiser l'islam qu'on reprenne
les théories napoléonienne du concordat
en 2016 franchement là je suis pas
passéiste mois dans la construction de
l'avenir
l'enseignement de la laïcité est une
mission aujourd'hui centrale pour
l'éducation nationale les incidents
observés dans les classes pendant la
minute de silence après les attentats de
janvier ont poussé le ministère à réagir
depuis septembre 2015 une réforme des
programmes est entrée en vigueur et le 9
novembre est devenu une journée
thématique dans tous les établissements
scolaires
c'est dans ce cadre qu'un groupe de
lycéens du val de marne a remporté un
concours organisé par le rectorat de
créteil
avec cette vidéo est laïcité c'est quoi
pour nous elle n'a pas de visage elle
n'a pas de religion
si tout
leur vision de la laïcité une valeur qui
protège chacun avec ses différences sans
chercher à uniformiser la laïcité s'est
ému parce que chacun nous représenter
une vision différente quand on arrive au
lycée et les musulmans y en a qui se
voilent dès qu'ils arrivaient devant le
lycée ils enlèvent les juifs pareil donc
dû rentrer au sein du lycée
en somme tous identiques ou semblent
tous égaux différents rime un peu de
tout et permet ça en fait voilà elle
permet de nous rassembler en tout cas un
discours construit grâce à un travail de
l'équipe éducative sensible à cette
question depuis plusieurs années la
méthode en cas d'incident adopter une
réponse graduée et pédagogique
on a été confrontés nous au sein du
lycée à des moments et les petits
arbitrages à faire de et puis parfois
mine de rien à une incapacité mellier a
certainement un manque de connaissance
d'un manque d'appréhension du sujet une
incapacité collective à traiter le
problème de manière souple et parfois
aussi parce que quand on ne maîtrise pas
le sujet et puis vu le sujet en question
et les réactions des groupes parfois
identitaire et communautaire
on devient un peu frileux pour parler
d'une seule voix le personnel du lycée a
accompli un travail de formation en
interne au quotidien la laïcité reste un
thème sensible mais n'est pas le sujet
de préoccupation numéro un qu'il
s'agisse de propos homophobes sexistes
racistes limite insultant voilà de
manière très générale infiniment plus
répandu que des atteintes à la laïcité
qui lui dans neuf cas sur dix soit on
ressent de plus sont d'abord y ait
effectivement à des situations
d'ignorance et une situation de
formation ça c'est quand même important
de le rappeler c'est à dire qu' on n'est
pas nous en tant que fonctionnaire les
voilà les bras armé de laïcité voilà qui
vit punitive
il s'agirait effectivement de dresser
des usagers entre les défenseurs d'une
laïcité intransigeante et les partisans
d'une vision plus souple le débat reste
ouvert
au sénat la proposition de loi des
radicaux a été rejetée ou l'adoption
vrai contre 200 le sénat n'a pas adopté
la loi de 1905 ne sera pas inscrite dans
la constitution la révision de la
constitution qui nous est ainsi proposée
mais pour effet de bouleverser les
équilibres subtils très subtil construit
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années et
qui garantisse le respect effectif des
principes essentiels que sont la liberté
de conscience le libre exercice du culte
et la séparation des églises et de
l'état
le législateur reste prudent sur la
question et laisse à la jurisprudence la
mission de fixer les contours de la
laïcité au fil des procédés polémique
autour de son application